good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday that
feels like a Monday so like it feels
like a little Dreadful but like it's
really not when you stop to think about
it it's not so Dreadful when you stop to
think about it we're like 30 through the
work week through the work week to the
work week I think we're 20 well I guess
10 from today already right 30 wow look
at that turdy I crunch the numbers and
they're all looking half bad they're not
so bad it's been a minute since we've
been here I hope everyone had an amazing
weekend we did fun friends family eras
and that's really all you can ask for
from a weekend fun friend family era
it's so true we were all in the city
this weekend because of Errors Taylor
like did kind of Ruin any potential
Memorial Day weekend plans and like I
wasn't I'm not gonna lie like in the
beginning like I was up feeling a little
bitter you know I can't take a trip
right but I actually ended up love
loving being home for the long weekend
the city was like kind of empty and it
just felt I kept thinking it was still
like pretty it wasn't totally empty like
some weekends holiday weekends it's for
like abandoned yeah but it was like
pretty
pretty fine and I was thinking like I
wish the city was always like this you
know just like a normal amount of people
on the street not you wish for happiness
like this forever literally that's how I
felt Friday night at eras like I really
wished for happiness like this forever
well I want to hear greatest showman
yeah yeah yeah I want to hear all about
eras eras well I was always planning on
going Saturday night like I had tickets
with a well I didn't have tickets a
brand offered me Margo and Ben seats in
there sweet so like I always knew I was
going and I was gonna try and get
tickets the other night but I was pretty
content I have been already in Nashville
I was pretty content just going Saturday
and then Friday day you and I were just
like hanging out with rolled and the fam
and and I was checking on Two And snitch
we're on ticket Patrol we were just
checking and then we left your house at
like four o'clock maybe 3 30. and you
guys like you and Mom were like really
encouraging that we go and I was like
all right I mean like if you guys are
saying it like maybe we should I think
sometimes you know I we get a little
fanatical me and Margo with our
obsessions and like you guys always reel
us back in but you were encouraging it
so I was like oh if Jax is saying and
Mom is saying like I should definitely
go so I'm walking home from your apart
from your apartment
refreshing StubHub and at like 4 30 I'm
like Margo like just get dressed like
we're gonna go we we are gonna go and as
I'm doing my makeup these tickets pop up
on StubHub we had been watching them
drop slowly and at first like many
months ago we wanted to sit on the floor
but a lot of the footage that I've seen
from the show is like if you're on the
floor and you're not in the first three
rows like you really can't see anything
and even if you're in the first three
rows the stage is so big she spends like
10 of the time in front of you and then
other 90 away so like I think maybe the
hack here is lower bowl and we really
wanted first row lower ball tickets but
my god the guy on StubHub would not drop
the tickets he had so many tickets in
the first row for like six grand I'm
like oh this guy is nuts so we bought a
few rows back they were definitely like
double face value but we thought we got
a good deal because he had eventually
dropped them we bought the tickets at 4
30 as we were getting dressed so we ran
we got dressed we literally didn't look
like special or amazing we just like
looked normal but whatever
um and we got to the stadium at like
6 30 we took an Uber like it wasn't
really crazy planned and we got there
the whole first row was empty the guy
never sold the tickets we were so mad
and we asked did you take those Seasons
we asked the security guard like could
we sit there and he was like no I'm like
okay and might you ask it was actually a
conversation between me and Margo like
do we ask or not ask and I think it's
you know Margo wanted to ask I wanted to
not ask
Margo ended up asking and he said no and
I was like damn we shouldn't have asked
and then five minutes later he was like
go I think he saw us having like the
best time we literally had the whole
first row to ourselves it was so stupid
I didn't know that it was so stupid that
no one was sitting there yeah but I
wasn't for asking exactly yeah and then
I didn't know that he eventually let you
sit there yeah and this was literally in
like the second era so we were literally
there the whole show and then I was like
you know what I'm glad we asked because
he uh you know respected us as being
rural followers respecting his authority
and then he ended up giving our seats to
this little girl so she got an upgrade
we got an upgrade it was all good and
fun
um he really should have given like the
front row seats to the little girl
because she was so short but whatever
I'm not complaining we the whole first
round we were like running and dancing
and oh my god did we have the time of
our lives like it was
the best heiress tour I've been to one
because it was clearly like a special
night we got a lot of surprises of
course we got ice spice we got amazing
special songs we got getaway car and
maroon she also then you know brought
out all of her dancers they all sat down
on the stage and she's like I'm gonna
Premiere my new music video for you it's
out at midnight but we're all gonna
watch it together so it was like a
special night you know and it was it was
really just amazing like being there
with counts like just it was I really
can't put into words it was the best
concert I've ever been to the best
arrows toy I've ever been to and then it
took a lot of pressure off the next
night because we were in a suite and
like technically it was like a work
event so we couldn't like be animals so
we were still you know vibing but we
weren't being like we got it all out of
our systems on Friday night so I feel
like I I hacked it perfectly we were
even thinking of going Sunday but at
that point I was like you know what let
someone else go we've we've seen enough
and I was beat like I was not okay like
three hours it was basically three hour
workout jumping dancing I didn't sit I
sat in between eras while she was doing
her outfit changes and there was like
music playing I needed you know the
break but I was up in Adam George
McFadden for the rest yeah it was
incredible and then on the second night
we were able to get merch and I got the
CD with the new song even though like
even though you trashed it on the show
last week the idea of it I have it as
like a novelty I'm never gonna listen to
the song I don't have a CD player or a
car or like a computer with a CD-ROM
so but like maybe one day you could sell
it to a fellow Swifty yeah that's
definitely what I'm thinking you know
keeping it in good condition I was
cracking up when you and Margaret were
like posting the CD after everything you
said last week on the show about the
idea of the CD no one think about me
like I'm like I'm gonna make fun of
something and like still do it you know
yeah because that's just me and you got
merch I got merch I got you we got you
merch yeah I got a t-shirt I got a
quarter zip which feels appropriate if
you've seen my comedy show so true and
it was just a fabulous weekend and then
also like I was able to like sing my
heart out Friday and Saturday night and
then literally all day Friday and Sunday
I was with you enrolled like yeah what
more could you ask for in a balanced
weekend it was such a balanced weekend
we had so much fun I mean I didn't have
the iris portion but it was really fun
to be in the city it was gorgeous
weather this weekend I couldn't ask for
better and we just got to spend a lot of
time outside Harry was having a blast we
went out to brunch we went to water park
we went to the perk we were part girly
swirly we were Park Early swirls it was
really fabulous like enriching
yeah yeah I wouldn't have done it any
other way Jax yeah well I'm glad that it
all worked out for you yeah and now
that's it that's a wrap on the arrows
tourney's version
we'll see where else would you go I
don't know Pittsburgh
no it's close
you would really go yeah I would go but
you didn't go to night three I didn't
next uh next backyard yeah no I didn't
are you really considering it yeah like
I support whatever you do if I have a
free weekend and there's like a good
destination why not okay you know and so
let's talk about all in all the secret
songs that you've cured for yourself yes
because in Nashville it was out of the
woods and 15 which was
amazing like they weren't even on my
list and I couldn't have asked for two
better songs and I really thought like I
got I got special treatment you know
then night one you had getaway car and
maroon maroon uh when she and she
brought Jack Anton off out like Friday
it was like a special night she treated
it differently I'm so glad I went and
then the Saturday night was Holy Ground
holy holy and then false god which was
okay
like those the first of the three out of
the woods 15 and Holy Ground no Out of
the Woods getaway cars get away card
Holy Ground like would have been on my
top yeah even maybe five let me tell you
something though like a uh I'm gonna
have a a bone to pick with Miss taylord
she obviously kept choosing songs that
had the word New York in it Holy Ground
is like all about the city
um
false god is staring at the window like
I'm not your favorite Town maroon it
says New York it's like all about New
York when I tell you at the concert
she's like hey Jersey she kept she never
called us New York and then she said
welcome to New York on the third night
she kept calling us chairs and like we
me and my were looking at each other it
was like stop it's a problem I know it's
a problem that the New York stadium is
in New Jersey but the New York Giants
play there the New York Jets play there
like when a big artist comes to town
they play there and then like their
Instagram caption is like East
rutherfordy were amazing and it's like
question you question mark who's Easter
Rutherford I don't know her so I was
well I appreciated the thought she put
into the secret songs like stop calling
us New Jersey but she's in New Jersey
but it's a stadium for New Yorkers too I
know but if she got up there and said
like hey New York people she would be
like trolled for not knowing where she
is and it's factually inaccurate like
there's no winning I just wish she said
hey
guys frustrating for her too why is
there not like a state what's the
stadium there's so many Arenas in New
York but is there not a stadium no
I guess that's why the New York Giants
and the New York Jets maybe like where
the Buffalo Bills play right I guess you
would say New York and that would feel
wrong too
then she could finally say New York hmm
it was weird
um but so they were thought put into the
secret songs like she always is yeah but
she reps sometimes it's just like a song
that feels good but she referenced in
maybe like four out of six of the secret
songs this weekend New York
then the third night was the much
dreaded Welcome to New York everyone was
like I'm not going the first night
because she's obviously going to play
Welcome to New York and I don't want to
hear that I just have to say like while
I wouldn't have chosen it Welcome to New
York is a banger like no it's not I feel
like people who actually are not Taylor
Swift fans like it more than Taylor
Swift yeah because it's like
I don't from that movie yeah the uh
Dakota Johnson how to be single yeah and
it was like part of the New York tourism
commercial so it's just like was it yeah
it's for the knot fans oh okay
um but I I feel like if and it's not
even close to a song that I even like
love I I could tolerate it I feel like
if you're in New York and she's here and
she sings it and it's like a one-time
only thing like it probably is a nice
moment but but we're in New Jersey
makes you think yeah
welcome to New Jersey
I missed it I'm okay with it she also
then then did sing clean which is the
first time she's repeated a song now and
of all the songs to repeat like that's a
really good one I definitely I was I was
having fomo from that oh were you yeah
you were having fun from one song yeah
not enough to like you know get tickets
and go but it was a tough loss for the
community I just think you're not seeing
what's in directly in front of you which
is the amazing songs I got unreal songs
no I have literally and you had maroon
because she knew that the songwriter
that inspired the song was in the crowd
yeah because a lot of people do say like
my recent Banger 100 sounds a lot like
Maroon and let's keep in mind 100 came
out a full year before maroon and that's
the thing by Taylor She's inspired by
others she said it herself so I'm
honored to be a part of the creative
process yeah they do sound similar and
we're not being crazy other people have
said it too wait we have spoken for so
long without talking about why today's
episode is so special
because our interview yeah Oh I thought
you forgot no no I just I there's so
many things that make at any given
episode Special
yeah I thought I didn't know if it was
this or that or like maybe something I
did I forgot like so if you're listening
as a podcast or watching as a video it's
at the end of today's episode we have a
30 minute interview with Brooke EB who
is kind of the trifecta if you will
she's a toaster
she's an advocate and she's a tick
talker so last week I got tagged in this
video like a thousand times I'm like oh
my God I'm blowing up what's going on
and not to make everything about me and
everyone was tagging me in this video
this beautiful young girl named Brooke
EB who makes videos about her terminal
ALS diagnosis and somebody had asked her
if she had any sort of bucket list you
know the wish list yeah like things she
wanted to do and she had a bunch of
different things Taylor Swift was on
there and the toast was on going on the
toast going on an episode of the toast
was like one of her major life goals so
we did it we made it happen what if we
just called brooka and that's exactly
what we did I slid into her DMS on Tick
Tock we organized it she came on the
toast last week right after we wrapped
for the week and it's at the end of
today's episode she's so funny she talks
a lot about her ALS journey and just
like you know questions people like have
for her that you might be wondering like
how does somebody you know go to work
you know things like that and then she
fulfills her toast fantasies by giving
us like a Fast Five hot take
conversation about Kardashians about
skandival about succession she was
really funny and she was really cute and
pretty and it was just a really fun
episode so it was so toasty it was like
it was so fun to talk to someone who
like knows what we're about to say knows
the lingo knows the lingo she was again
to lingo before we were yeah it was
great so that's at the end of today's
episode and it's really I think one of
my favorite interviews ever yeah also at
the after the past five shall be
succession recap oh yeah because Claudia
and I both watched the finale and boy am
I glad I did it was amazing yeah yeah
there's a lot it was so vindicating
fulfilling for those of us who [__]
hate those kids yeah and I couldn't have
dreamed up A better ending for the show
that hurt more people
it was beautiful yeah it was but it was
interesting you know what I'll get into
it because I do also have some mixed
thoughts yeah but remember when the
season premiered and we said who do you
think
will will succeed like who will take
over what do we say I forget who you
said but it was also not like who do you
think but who do you want yeah and I
said Maxim I said you're not wrong and I
wasn't wrong yeah
must be nice
I wonder who you said probably something
so dumb like Marsha or something like
one thing about me like I do not
understand succession like the business
stuff like I always have to go on
Twitter afterwards and like see if I
missed anything because so much of it
goes over my head so but then you go on
Twitter and you see people who are
seriously mentally ill yeah
crying over what they feel like in
Kendall just deserves more like it was
kind of deserves more he's literally a
murderer Kendall deserves nothing he's
literally murderer yep literally one of
the worst human beings on the face of
the planet terrible businessman terrible
father terrible husband at its core
terrible son at his core and why Logan
like never handed over the business like
he was the only one who was qualified
but he didn't have it he was like kind
of dumb like always making you knew if
Kendall said to do this the right answer
was it was that yeah he was just he
didn't have the brains for it so really
none of them were deserving equipped or
qualified or qualified so the best man
won in my opinion yeah the man who's
always been there for the company always
been there for Logan no and the man who
will admit like is really just a pawn
he's like Madison was like I need you
like I want to put my finger up your ass
and you're going to be my puppet and
he's more he's not scrupled he'll say
this say that just he's perfect for that
world yeah so the right man won in my
opinion agreed okay we'll talk we'll
talk about it at the end even though we
just talked about it so let's dive in
let's dive in any other Eris turny's
version thoughts we're going to talk
more errors in the past right there's a
bunch of story world the first story so
if I forgot anything I'll get to it
great so now without further Ado here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
the Kardashians on Hulu you can watch
the all new season of the Kardashians
new episodes are dropping Thursdays only
on Hulu so the world's most famous
matriarchy is back for the most intimate
look yet inside the family Empire we
know that there's a lot going down in
the Kardashian universe and we're
finally gonna get to hear from the
ladies themselves a lot of speculation
on you know divorce the whole Courtney
Kim thing like we don't really know
what's going on and the Kardashians are
getting into it on their new season
season three of the Kardashians on Hulu
so they're talking entrepreneurship
their sibling rivalry there's Newfound
love there's family growth there's
business motherhood and more we'll see
each of the six women more up close and
personal than ever as they can continue
to evolve with what it means to be a
Kardashian we know you love them we love
them the whole gangle the gang of the
girlies is there there's Chris Courtney
Kim Chloe Kendall Kylie I'm kind of in
my Kindle era these days I've been
really like I know after the first
episode from last week I really
um I was feeling Kendall wow I'm always
in my Kylie era especially as she was
learning to drive stick I'm always in my
Chloe era always always but I really
related to Kylie learning how to drive
yeah
um so you don't miss the season three of
the Kardashians new episodes are
dropping Thursdays only on Hulu you can
catch up now on all the seasons and the
first episode which premiered last week
the Kardashians season three new
episodes are dropping Thursdays only on
Hulu you don't want to miss it today's
episode is also brought to you by
Caraway get a head start on spring
cleaning with Caraway their thoughtfully
designed sets and complementary storage
makes getting and staying organized
easier than ever you can now save 10 off
the full Suite of Caraway products from
the internet famous cookware to their
newly launched food storage set
caraway's high quality ceramic coated
kitchenware is free of PTFE like Teflon
lead cadmium and other toxic materials
um Jax I know you're like a ride or die
Caraway girl and you've been kind of
away from home no I've been struggling
because since I've been here and now I'm
going to be here for a few months like I
was like you know what I'm not gonna get
like Caraway pots and pans like it just
seems excessive but I caved and I
ordered an other set because I actually
find myself cooking less because it's
like oh I don't want to make eggs
they're going to stick to the pan so
true I need my Caraway cookware so I
have the set um I have the frying pan
already and the rest of the things I
think they're being delivered today I'm
so excited like it makes me cook more to
use Caraway because it's such a pleasant
experience and the cleanup is so easy
they're they're pot should be called the
chili pot yeah because it's amazing for
chili so true but maybe like a summer
soup maybe like a gazpacho I'll make
this a gazpacho a gazpacho by the
Caraway the thing I like about caraways
like yeah there's all these great fancy
things like if you live with a Ben
Soffer who will leave a pan out for
months before he cleans it it's such a
relief to like seriously Ben will leave
it out all day and there's like stuck on
cheese and you rinse it and it's so easy
to clean it really makes the cleanup
more
realistically doable and it makes you
not want to kill your husband which is
always taking good marriages visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com
zero or just use code toast10 at
checkout Caraway non-toxic cookware made
Modern also the non-toxicity is key
especially I cook Harry's food of course
so it's like he's not going to now go to
having toxins no no not on my watch no
okay our first Story Taylor Swift took
the era's tour to MetLife Stadium there
was Ice spice there was Jack Antonoff
there was Aaron Rodgers Miles Teller
Kelly teller Paul Rudd Sean and Camilla
Mendes there were so many when I was
there I saw Mariska Hargitay wow I got a
great picture of Herman I didn't see him
just maresh Mariska Hargitay Molly
Ringwald I thought they were just being
you know were they all in the tent yes
well something interesting that happened
was in our section was Kate Upton we
were like why isn't Kate Upton in the
tent and then Mariska was like staring
at our section our section was right
behind the celebrity tent so we saw
everything and she's talking to security
guard she's on the phone and she's
looking up and then Kate Upton
disappears and never comes back so I
want to believe that Mariska was
coordinating Kate's arrival to the tent
because Marisha is like a an OG Taylor
fan I feel like she has pull in the tent
yeah but what's the relationship between
Kate and Marishka I don't know I just
feel like celebrities know each other
and you know now Kate Upton is like a
New York Elite because her husband plays
for the Mets and Marisha is literally no
no no she went to eras without her
daughter did she win just by herself I
don't remember I don't I wasn't looking
at the people around her I was literally
just looking at her Fair
um so Molly Ringwald the night that we
went Hoda Molly Ringwald
um lin-manuel Miranda Marishka Kate
Upton
there were a lot of people that you went
yeah Nikki Hilton was there with her
daughters but they weren't they weren't
in the town I think they weren't a suite
yeah
um
yeah the next night Paul Rudd
Aaron Rodgers Miles Teller that that
whole crew
um
Camilla and Sean oh Marin Morris went
um a lot of other people it was like
really star-sided I feel like they had
to make the tent bigger yeah like
usually it's like two or three but they
were like tons of a-listers I mean I
don't know how big they're gonna have to
make the tent in L.A well that's what I
chose there's five shows and the uh the
ten was interesting because her family
has their own tent they're not in the
celebrity tent I don't know if that's
always been that way but now there's two
tens
wow like family and then friends and
celebrities and um Julia Gardner was
there yeah tonight yes yes yes and
adelphy was there so so good to see her
out doing well yeah um it was popping
like honestly the hottest ticket in town
yeah it really was and it's just crazy
all those people like for Soca Memorial
Day plans right to be with tailored
right unless they like you know just
flew in from the Hamptons I actually did
see um which was cool when we were
pulling up there's like a helicopter
landing and there was one Landing like
on the pad so we were like trying to see
who it was but they literally just were
ushered literally from the helicopter to
an SUV into a tunnel like into the
stadium so I was thinking maybe it was
Taylor like it was Elite treatment
that's crazy yeah so how I spice
performed the three nights Karma because
also all the songs dropped so right it's
different the new Vault track you're
losing me and then the ice spice Karma
and the Lana Del Rey yeah which has more
Lana yeah it's hard for me when I'm
listening to like realize that there's a
difference you know what I mean I like
the old version I'm fine with it
um what's with the new tracks like
what's the hidden meanings what are we
learning I haven't listened to you're
losing me yet I just honestly didn't
find the time this weekend and I've been
so I listened on repeat literally this
morning it hits different is probably
one of my favorite Taylor songs ever
like it is so good oh wow I did a story
this morning like asking people what do
you want in the Fast Five and like a
couple people wrote like you're losing
me and I was like that's [__] rude
like what did I do that like
you know you guys hurt Jax this morning
no but then I realized the song the song
because someone said you're losing me
Taylor's and so I was like oh okay so
that's all there is it's funny there's
all there is to say about that yeah oh
yeah no there people are um like
dissecting the bridge and who would want
to I wouldn't want to marry me either a
pathological people pleaser now
everyone's looking at midnights like as
a breakup album when at first it didn't
occur to anyone because she was with Joe
because she was with Joe but it's most
likely that she was writing these songs
during you know the end of their
relationship and and when things started
to go awry and now you're looking at it
with a new lens
I don't know
I don't think maybe it's like one or two
of them but I don't think you can like
say that about the whole album because
one didn't she say early on like these
are the songs about things in my life up
at midnight yeah these are different
nights throughout my life of things that
like keep you up so I think it's like
it's a good point more history there and
two like she just writes about random
[__] at this point like the Great War is
apparently about Lady Mary and cousin
Matthew no [__] way I didn't hear
that how would I have heard that about
you it totally is
I'm obsessed yeah she's she now and she
has said like ever since folklore and
Evermore like we really don't need to
like dissect the lyrics as much as we do
because she'll write it up based off of
a movie she watched or a book that she
read or something her friend is going
through like a lot of the songs on not a
lot but like two on folklore and
Evermore are about Abigail's divorce so
it's not about Taylor per se so we don't
really need to look at it through that
lens anymore you know what I was
thinking about this weekend which was
funny it's like how we speculate like
which song is about like Taylor losing
her virginity and when and it's like but
we all know when Abigail did we all know
in Abigail did
because back then she swore she was
going to marry him someday you know yeah
and Abigail was so brave for that like
yeah I mean I'm sure she didn't think
like her friend who was like playing her
guitar at the time was gonna literally
become the biggest star in the world and
like one of her biggest songs was gonna
be the song about her Abigail losing her
virginity I'm sure she's a boy who
changed his mind and we both cried right
like I'm sure she just thought she would
like put it on YouTube and that would be
the end of it right no she's gonna
perform at night too in Nashville eras
towards right 70 000 people yeah
I think Abigail has healed you know was
there a rumor at one point that there
was a riff between them I didn't hear
that oh okay Abigail's like about
Abigail's divorce then yeah so Abigail
has like a kind of like a crazy like
thing going on I think like there was
infidelity and now she's like with the
guy I don't know
what song is reportedly about Abigail's
divorce tolerate it okay and happiness
got it two of the worst songs in my
opinion
also I think it's like nice that Taylor
could like write a really
a beautiful like song No and then if she
doesn't want to like expose herself as
like this is about me there's this
mystery of like it could be about
anything no but there's also like the
I think a part of Taylor probably
worries like you know if everything
settles down in her life like what will
she write about and like the fact that
she some of her I would say her best
work folklore and Evermore actually like
really not about her
um is great like she doesn't have to
keep living and like breaking up and
making up like she can settle she's
constantly inspired right and it's cool
to be inspired by books and and she's
inspired by those writers Lakes the
Lakes she was definitely inspired by
Evelyn Hugo when she wrote champagne
problems you truly cannot convince me
otherwise yeah you love to see it yeah
and Evelyn Hugo was definitely inspired
by her
said it's like it's not not like you
know well I think that book and other
books like it are like accumulations
character of a lot of different
characters yeah composite characters of
different characters composite
characters of composited characters who
are Composites of other people and
they're composited together it really is
a competition the composition don't you
think a composition of one character
right who's an accumulation of multiple
characters
in that composite exactly well congrats
on a great weekend tailored I I'm gonna
get dressed in stay alert this week you
are yeah where is she going next Chicago
she's definitely going to be in New York
until she has to go to Chicago okay and
oh we didn't talk about Aaron Rodgers
who's a big Swifty we had been knowing
this because we were literally obsessed
with that video Kelly Taylor posted of
her Aaron Rodgers Shailene Woodley and
Miles all vibing out to the one in
Hawaii like literally Taylor said it
best like everybody time flies
but I'm right where you left me I'm
right where you left me at that video
like I have not moved on from that video
no and Aaron Rodgers is a folklore girly
yes he's definitely yeah and so a lot of
people were filming him during the show
when the everyone is living his best
life he was having fun I think he has
like a kind of like a reputation for
being like a little bit of like a
like a sourpuss you know okay so it was
nice to see him like living his best
life and you know what like this is kind
of in my opinion gonna be the
Renaissance of of Aaron Rodgers like in
terms of celebrity because he's now like
you know the number one guy in New York
yeah he's gonna bring this defunct
franchise hopefully into a new era and I
think a lot of people are putting like a
lot of pressure on him and I think he's
gonna I think he's gonna show up for us
do you think he's gonna rise to the
occasion I do I won't lie I did miss
Shailene in those videos I know her
absence was felt by me I would have
loved to see her like running around
Barefoot in the tent yeah
yeah
that was tough yeah
but I'm glad that the crew was still
crewing yeah the tellers and the Rogers
yeah
okay ready for our next story which is
so if I could challenge Jason and come
back to life as one person like it might
be Kelly teller yeah
for so many reasons
but her Association to Taylor is
definitely up there oh yeah but that's
not even like number top three no she's
literally gorgeous she's married to
Miles Teller she's like such a cool
family like they're all like always
hanging out and like being best friends
and they're all sisters and the husbands
are what's that like yeah no it's like
it's giving us but like better and like
non-jewish you know like they're
literally like giving non-jewish ashrae
energy and they have like kids and
they're like always going on vacation
like it's just really looks nice yeah
what's the Taylor adjacent story Maddie
Healy Oh what now he gave an interview
to the New Yorker and he's uh dismissing
deluded podcast controversy she amid the
Taylor romance rumors so three months
after Maddie Healy recorded a
controversial Adam Friedland Show
podcast episodes he wants haters to
shake it off in the 1975 front man told
a New Yorker in an interview published
Monday that his February comments don't
actually matter and we're a little bit
bait for naysayers he said quote nobody
is sitting there at night slumped at
their computer and their boyfriend comes
over and goes what's wrong darling and
they go it's just this thing with Maddie
Healy he said that doesn't happen and
then when he subsequently acknowledged
that maybe it does happen he called
those affected people deluded
individuals he said you're either lying
that you were hurt or you're a bit
mental for being hurt it's just people
going oh there's a bad thing over there
let me get as close to it as possible so
you can see how good I am and I kind of
want them to do that because their
demonstrating something so base level
it's a very brave hot take on like
internet culture
um and kind of Stan culture too because
like when someone you'd like or idolize
you know maybe makes a decision or does
something that you don't wholeheartedly
agree with people love to be like this
really hurts and I think we need to be
really careful about language because
you're not hurt you're living your life
and really this has not affected you
whatsoever so I think what what he's
saying and I actually really agree with
is like the way Stan culture like
manipulates language and also like blows
things out of proportion all the time it
really needs to be spoken about like
more more so than anything yeah I think
it's a really fresh take yeah I I
appreciate it and I don't think he's
wrongly it really doesn't affect
people's day-to-day and if it does like
and maybe it does that's a you problem
no and that's really like a
psychological issue that that person
needs to work on because if you're
letting the words and by the way what's
so interesting and I've really and in
this case it's not even the words of
like your favorite
1975 front man it's the words of your
favorite girl's boyfriend right it's
really like so disconnected and it's so
far removed but the way people really
like
and wrap themselves in celebrities is
really toxic and this is like the
perfect example of that like you should
not be personally offended by what
someone who you've never met has done or
said you know it's not it's not healthy
no no but it's also just like offense
culture well of course and that's what
he's saying it's like it's not about
people actually being offended it's like
them having something to say against you
and just like being so excited to have
like the moral High Ground I also think
sometimes when things like this happen
it's not that always just the stands who
are like grabbing their pictures it's
just anybody who wants to feel like
morally Superior being like you did a
bad thing right right and I don't know
just like for me even if like the person
who I love most in this world like in
terms of celebrity and Idol is really
Taylor and if she did something that
like or said said something that like I
really disagree with like
sure would I care yes would I literally
move on with my life and like would my
life be affected no has she never said
anything that you disagree with up until
this point of course she has but doesn't
even register yeah because you just move
on right and you could still love
somebody like this whole concept that
like you can only be a fan of somebody
who agrees with every single principle
it literally reminds me when Jay said he
was on the podcast he was like talking
about how it's important to date someone
with similar values to you but at the
end of the day like your values are like
DNA like they're even someone even you
and I have different values but we're so
different because it's so specific to
literally who you are in every Human
Experience you've ever had and so to
expect that of someone and to project
that on someone is so toxic
impossible it's impossible I was having
this conversation with someone I feel
like sometimes you talk about someone
and it's like well I don't agree with
everything that they think it's like I
couldn't name one person on this Earth
who I agree with about every single
literally you and I not even not even
you know we agree about 99.99 of things
no and that's okay and it's like what
happened to celebrate what what happened
to hello how are you like this qualifier
you have to put in front of everything
yeah no it's like well duh duh we're all
different people we've all experienced
different things right so uh people and
then the people who he's talking to in
this article then I saw in Tick Tock
they were like I'm so upset like really
people need to touch grass they
absolutely got to get off the internet
like some people just can't handle the
internet and I think that's okay but
they need to acknowledge there's the
most internet I know and they have like
power they're the most they're spending
the most Time online right it's a their
insane content and backlash requires
Matty Healy to do stuff like this this
article yeah yeah but I also think he
likes like ruffling everyone's feathers
he does and letting them know that he
still doesn't care and they're not
getting their apology yeah no he does
this thing now at the beginning not the
beginning in the middle of his shows
where he talks in between songs but um
he's like about to say something crazy
and the music Cuts him off like the band
comes in so he's like is it anti-timetic
to say and then the band comes in and
it's like it's funny like it's it really
is like a joke and I think people really
honey I saw one of those and they do it
at like everyone like taken out of
context I thought it was just one it's
like even his band doesn't want him to
speak because they know what he says
it's gonna be so terrible right but he's
clearly like he's clearly commentating
on the state of culture but some people
are too dense and too in it to even see
that like they're actually being mocked
yeah but they don't they don't see it
they're like look he can't hold himself
back people are so not [__] okay like
honestly this is funny to me it is it is
funny to me and I'm I'm shipping for
tailored no me too obsessed even though
he wasn't under the concerts this
weekend but I think he had work to do
like you know he's also he's been really
a celebrity yeah
are you ready for our next story some
more concert news but not tailored yes
proud mom Beyonce Praises her daughter's
parents Paris performance Beyonce paid
tribute to daughter Blue Ivy following
the 11 year old surprise Cameo during
her mom's Renaissance Tour on Friday she
said my beautiful firstborn I'm so proud
and thankful to be your mama you bring
us so much joy My Sweet Angel that's so
cute Blue Ivy came out during uh
Beyonce's performance of her song my
power and she sang along with the she
danced along with the dancers I thought
I was like oh I didn't see your saying
no no she's a very good dancer yeah like
she was Keeping Up with the professional
choreography yeah and I think she came
out before the next night yeah I saw two
different videos of her dancing this is
the kind of autism I absolutely love to
say totally like obsessed and it's just
like fun for the fans yeah and she like
if you're you know zoomed out on the
show like it's just another dancer like
she's keeping up she's not a detriment
right right I think it's awesome and
it's such a cool opportunity especially
if she loves to dance like why not dance
on the biggest stage in the world right
what if I just what if I
and went on the Renaissance tour so cool
she looked great she kept up she's a
very very skilled dancer and Beyonce's
dancers I mean all dancers on like big
tours do the most like Beyonce's dancers
really take it to like another level so
her being able to keep up like I see a
future for blue yeah Kylie was at
Beyonce's show in Paris yes Kylie was
stunted on them hoes in the ocean she
was stunted on those Parisian hoes she
was stunted on that Cobblestone she was
having a great weekend in Paris I loved
the Chanel looks were they all Chanel I
think so I thought some she's like
they're she's like the new face of dng
also oh how does Courtney feel about it
I know because like I saw on her stories
like there was pictures of her like in
the display oh I'm so sorry I I thought
they were all Chanel but I might just be
I don't even know I'm thinking where did
I hear that Dolce I didn't hear Chanel
she was just giving a very classy energy
yeah maybe I assumed no I'm I'm not
making that up like I heard it somewhere
I'm gonna google
I'm gonna Google would you Google
Kylie Jenner Dolce Gabbana okay now
Google Kylie Jenner Chanel okay
I would love that for her I mean they
looked so like crisp white Chanel
two days ago she stopped by the Chanel
store oh okay okay in a in a white mini
skirt and matching Blazer but who made
that outfit that white outfit was like
the one yeah she looked so adorable but
she's also like she's been doing a lot
of Couture stuff and sheets really she
did John Paul jpg jpg not the Nazi it's
very confusing Jean-Paul Gautier yeah
very different than oh here's John
Gagliano who's very different from Jean
Valjean she is wearing a look by
Maximilian Davis oh okay oh you could
buy it now how much is it 435 for the
skirt on matches fashion okay this is
like less than I expected no yeah I
thought this yeah was like you know
bespoke it's so cute I accept these
cookies oh and the top is on sale for
725 wow Kylie wearing a thousand dollar
look Thrifty Queen like I love organista
she's a Max and he stuff yeah she's
Balling on a budget Balling on a budget
tough times over at Kylie Cosmetics um
it's such a cute outfit I can't believe
it's so accessible like if it only would
fit me right now I would snatch it up
her stories
um at the concert like looked so fun I
love when Kylie just like Kylie doesn't
go on the night out with her friends but
when she does she goes big she's doing
the most she's lying to Paris she's in
the Box she's taking everyone with her
they're drinking yeah they're making
Tick Tock full Glam it's like a it's a
quarterly Affair no I feel like it
depends on the season of her life you
know yeah of course because there was a
time when it was like a weekly Affair
and she really loves more than any of
the other girls like part yeah she's the
youngest like yeah I literally forget
she's the youngest because she's so
mature and like her business and her
family like she's got it all secured but
she's literally like 24. no she's like
20 she I think she's turning 27. really
yeah is she older younger than the
snatchler that's a good question age her
birthday's in August oh she's 25 right
now and she's turning 26. that's
literally so young yeah she's Margo yeah
just like a little cooler
just a little
no I really mean it just a little
Margo's really cool Margo's really cool
you got to spend a lot of time with her
this weekend I know like I don't know
her updates if era's Tour on Friday
night was so amazing because the show
was so amazing or because I got like the
most quality undivided core memory
attention from this natural like that
was the best part of the night what'd
you guys talk about like in the car on
the way there
that's a good question we talked we
actually talked at like the whole car
ride that's so natural we were like
planning Logistics charging our phones
she's not super chatty in general but
like if you get her in a car she'll
start talking no she won't she should
hang out with her in cars more often we
should get I've actually been thinking
like I'm I think it's time for like the
first time in my life like I need to get
a car and now and maybe I'll just drive
around town and scoop up the snatcher
I'll be here to chauffeur that would be
good for your relationship with her
she'll sit in the back and I'll sit in
the front and she'll just start talking
yeah
yeah so what'd you guys talk about
it's like everything do you think like
more like era stuff or like life stuff
like both interesting I was gonna say I
was trying to remember if you came up
but like I don't think you did
sorry it's okay it's better than you
coming up and her having something bad
to say so so just kind of blessings
so true friendship lessons are you ready
for our next story if it's the next
story that's brought to you by bowling
Branch tis wake up feeling rusted and
refreshed with the softest most
luxurious sheets from Bowling Branch
bowling branch is the betting expert
they make the highest quality sheets
with Incredible craftsmanship each sheet
set is slow made for an unmatched
softness with 100 traceable organic
cotton that gets softer with every wash
so Jax and I have been bowling Branch
girlies for a while like we hate to say
I told you so but every time we convert
one of you you're like oh my God I can't
believe it like we told you we sat here
for years telling you yeah I don't know
how many words I can say it like you
want to trust me on one thing all right
maybe you don't trust me on like which
you know produce is the best but you can
trust me on which sheets are the best
because I'm a sleep expert and bowling
Branch are the Sleep Experts we both
have the signature hem sheets collection
from Bowling Branch it's their best
seller for a reason they are superior in
softness and they get they really just
they give you a better night's sleep
they feel buttery to the touch they are
super breathable and they're perfect for
both cooler and warmer weather they're
loved by millions of sleepers they have
been below loved by over not over sorry
excuse me I've been beloved by four U.S
presidents and they have over ten
thousand rave reviews they come in 10
versatile colors and all sizes so
whether you have a twin bed they go all
the way up to California King they're
incredible for all sleepers and they're
made without toxins synthetic pesticides
formaldehyde other harsh chemicals get
better sleep at night with bowl and
brown sheets get 15 off your first order
when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusion Supply Seaside for
details we love their sheets but we also
love a lot of their accessories like our
throw blankets are from there waffle
blank the waffle blanket we have a lot
of their stuff today's episode is also
brought to you by Quince shopping for
clothes is a compromise it often feels
like we have to choose between saving up
for an expensive luxury piece or
settling for a cheap fast fashion item
that will not last that was until we
elevated our closet with Quince with
Quince we get high quality Timeless
pieces without paying a luxury price tag
they offer a range of must-haves like
100 Mongolian cashmere sweaters for only
fifty dollars the sweater that I wore
the toast when I Did Paige de Sorbo
episode everyone was like oh man you
look amazing and Paige actually said I
looked like a rich older woman like
Coastal grandmother that was Quince
um so that was the Mongolian cashmere
sweater for only fifty dollars they have
a hundred percent European linen pants
for only forty dollars which is like
what everyone's wearing right now they
have luxurious Mulberry skill silk
skirts at sixty dollars and fifty dollar
Italian leather bags so all their pieces
are fifty to eighty percent less than
similar luxury Brands and that's because
Quince creates Timeless classic styles
that won't go out of fashion so you'll
have them in your closet forever so
again I got that cashmere sweater I also
got a really cute like cropped cardigan
everything I got from Quince is really
big again occurred again and they're
like you wouldn't remember it because
they're just staple pieces and you can
wear them like multiple times a week if
you style them differently I love to
repeat outfits
um Quince basically how they keep their
prices down is they partner directly
with top factories to cut the cost of
the middleman and pass the savings on to
you they only work with factories that
you save ethical and responsible
manufacturing practices and premium
eco-friendly Fabrics so we can feel good
about getting high quality items that
last longer shop with Quince today and
discover the affordable luxury that you
deserve right now go to quince.com toast
to get free free shipping and 365 day
returns on your next order that's
unheard of 365. you hear that Jack's
365. Dave returns six five three six
five that's Quince which is spelled
q-u-i leap year
I'll have to ask I'll get back to you
next time
q-u-i-n-c-e.com slash toast for free
shipping 365 day returns that's Quince
q-u-i-n-c-e.com slash t-o-a-s-t thank
you Claudia welcome our next story Tom
Sandoval was seen talking on the phone
with Raquel after breakup news yeah this
picture went viral of him on a plane on
the phone contact Raquel he was like on
a phone call and his phone was like kind
of turned outward like towards the
person taking the photos he was
intentional well then I fell down a
rabbit hole and Tick Tock of people
being like you know he's
doing you know PR there's like a lot of
speculation in the last couple of days
like he had broken up with Raquel he was
dating this influencer then that
influencer deactivated all of her
socials actually Kristen Dodie is on the
good guys podcast this week I was
watching it this morning I have like 10
minutes left
um and she was talking about how like he
was speculated to have been dating this
girl and then like the girl is an
influencer and she literally he
activated all of her social media maybe
because she didn't want to be associated
with Tom and like an influencer would
never because if an influencer was
actually dating him they would be like
eating all this up right
um
just quick shout out to the good guys so
I don't know what he would be getting
out of this if it is like a PR stunt it
just like looked it looked a little a
little staged but it also looked very
you know boots on the ground Tom in the
wild I don't think it's staged but I
also like really try to give people the
benefit of the doubt but I really could
imagine like he's hiding his face and I
feel like he thinks that like that's all
he's concerned about and doesn't realize
that yeah because we've never really
caught someone like this it's not like a
known it's very intimate like you know
what I mean like I feel like there's a
way where he didn't even realize that he
was showing people that because he was
more so worried about like himself which
is so Tom Sandoval yeah I wonder where
he was going he was on a plane I also
don't think that they broke up like
there's been so many rumors coming out
like I don't believe any of them yeah I
think that they are together and in love
I don't think she's pregnant but I would
sooner believe that she's pregnant that
that than that they broke up he was
dating someone else they're talking yeah
like this whole mess yeah yeah I don't
think he's dating someone else I do I'm
I mean I honestly hope they're still
together like for both of their sakes
mostly hers
um but I do think she's still in a
facility she hasn't been seen or heard
from so maybe she has her cell phone
right maybe it was like their weekly
call time I don't think she has like you
know unlimited access to her phone in a
place like that no she doesn't because
she's writing letters right the Morgan
ladder but I guess so letter said didn't
say dude
um maybe not well maybe it started out
Dear Tom but it wasn't a breakup letter
yeah it's like dear Tom the food is
great and I'm making a lot of friends
yeah dear Tom send socks I'm all out
like a camp yeah I used to like hate
writing letters at camp but you know
what when they used to have those books
of letters that were like kind of like
Mad Libs where it was I would fill it in
for my friends are blank I'm having a
blank time at camp and you would be like
awesome yeah it would make letter
writing so easy terrible right but now
um when I look back on like letter
writing at Camp it's like so I look back
on it so fondly like I wish I did it
more it's such a beautiful concept and
like you know at our camp some like
maybe once a week you would have to
write a letter
um you'd have to show up to dinner with
a letter just so like they made sure
everyone was writing their parents it
was nice now I guess they have like cell
phone time at Camp which is so crazy to
me and like honestly not to sound like a
grandma I think Camp was so amazing
because we were so disconnected like
friend from like friends from home like
it didn't matter there was no need to
like I wasn't writing my friends letters
at other camps I was just writing my
videos like once throughout the summer I
would exchange with like a inter Camp
letter but like Camp was its own
universe and everyone was in their own
campus you know oh yeah it didn't feel
like you were missing stuff at home but
like our parents like paid to like for
us to have this amazing time like the
least we could do was write them a
[__] letter yeah but I found it like
so Dreadful I'm like a letter I didn't I
was like I'm having a great time like
please you don't pick me up like I never
want to see you guys again like I loved
Camp so much like literally I I didn't
want to be connected to the outside
world right but I feel like when you
know your kids which you know most
parents do it's like not getting a
letter from it's a good sign it's a good
sign not getting a letter from most kids
is probably a good sign because you know
no news is good news right they're
having too much fun they're playing
Jacks at night they're not writing
letters in their bed alone with their
flashlight like that's something I'm
really excited about to have kids like
but I don't know how I'm gonna fare I'm
gonna be so jealous of my kids when they
go to camp but I guess that's like when
I'll travel and like get my life back
yeah but knowing that my kids are like
making memories like playing Jacks like
getting tan living like so Carefree
maybe having their first boyfriend like
I'll be so jealous I'm gonna show up at
Camp every day be like hey girls what's
up man I'm literally gonna be like the
mom that works at camp like I'm gonna be
there one one I'm gonna be the Arts and
Crafts teacher yeah because I love cam
so much no you'll have to create a life
for yourself that's outside more
exciting like maybe you get a lake house
and then you're with like oh fellow like
late couples and you're having your own
like adults if I get a lake house I will
be jealous all right put that on my list
of like I need like oh I just nevermind
um I have like a 10-year plan lake house
is one of them lake house greater than
beach house
like I can have them into the Lakey
Vibes maybe it's because last night I
literally finished meet me at the lake
the Carly Fortune book and she really
knows how to romanticize a lake her
books always take place in Toronto like
Lake Muskoka
um and I gotta go I started the new book
by May Cobb who wrote The Hunting way
that's what I'm gonna read next I think
you'll like it because it's pretty spicy
I don't remember hunting wives it was
there was a lot of like lesbian like all
these like straight married like uptight
rich women like [__] each other on
the weekends really yeah there was like
a lesbian undercurrent it was very sexy
I don't remember that because I was like
damn may come and now I'm like I put
this book on my story people think I'm
really important oh is it like full oh
now you're making me want to read it
even more
finish but I don't I have no idea what's
coming like maybe I'm gonna wait for you
to finish it like maybe it's good for my
book club oh I'll let you know but like
is spice good for the book club the book
club loves spice oh okay yeah we all we
all SWAP it's like there's something
about it I feel like you know when
you're reading something and it's like
this is so stupid and then but by the
end it makes sense like why all those
stupid things happen like someone was
intentionally being stupid right so I
don't want to judge it until I'm done
with it because right now it's like
I could poke a few holes okay I could
poke with you I also read the housemaid
this weekend oh yeah I read all weekend
I didn't watch TV except for succession
I read the housemate and the sequel so
good yeah I read it like really quick on
a weekend both of them both of them I
read in one day good good books the
second one I like started at noon and I
finished at 10 p.m there's she writes
like a lot of good thrillers like I
think she's an author now if you pick up
her book like you know it's good like a
Sally Hepworth you know she's a good
writer there were a lot of twists that I
didn't see coming yeah Freda McFadden I
would recommend okay good
are you ready for our fifth and final
story I am new couple alert Haley
Steinfeld has been dating Josh Allen for
a few weeks as a source they're having
fun yeah this was interesting Josh
Allen's like a star yeah hailee
Steinfeld and Josh Allen have been
hanging out for a few weeks a source
close to the couple told People magazine
um the cute couple have been
photographed together multiple times
over the last few days in New York City
why wasn't she at eras
yeah do they end on bad terms she was
like in the squad and then never to be
seen again yeah but she was really in
the squad she's kind of like one of the
Facebook members there were some randos
yeah of course we only got like the
invite once yeah but she's core Squad
yeah anyways The Insider said it's new
but they're having fun was he married
I don't think so I feel like they're
always doing packages about him on ESPN
like he's a star always
happening to watch them
no he's 27. oh he's young I'm not seeing
a marriage here Haley's time felt like
has an amazing dating track record like
Niall Horan okay Josh Allen and that's
all I can think of but I also like don't
fully believe Niall Horan like I feel
like that was more like PR convenient a
little bit I could see that having been
hailee Steinfeld like is such a good
level of celebrity I feel like she makes
a lot of money like she's very um A-list
but she's not like she probably is a
normal life like she can go to the
grocery store but she can date whoever
she wants you know yeah no I really I
love this for her if true I'm wondering
why they weren't at eras maybe they'll
be at the one at the Buffalo Bills there
isn't one maybe Pittsburgh I don't know
if Pittsburgh is close to Buffalo but I
feel like it is
I don't think it is I think it is Philly
south of here in Buffalo is north of
here such a good point yeah well
actually Pennsylvania is west of here
oh but still
Buffalo's North I'm just gonna I'm gonna
put this rumor to rest and figure it out
right now ready I guess we'll just look
at a map
Pittsburgh
to Buffalo
I'm just pulling up Google Maps like one
thing about me I don't know geography
and I never will it just really depends
for me
I'll go Pittsburgh so West where's
Buffalo okay they're like not far from
each other but they're not I'm just like
not seeing Buffalo they're actually like
by the way what's so crazy is like
Pennsylvania and buffalo
and Pittsburgh Buffalo are so far from
here like you think it's all like
Northeast it's so far no Pittsburgh is
like on the Western border of
Pennsylvania and buffalo was literally
in Canada
yeah when I did a show in like Buffalo
Rochester area people were like driving
from Toronto
oh actually I'm sorry Buffalo would be
closer to Pittsburgh it's kind of a
triangle but the Buffalo side is closer
to Pittsburgh much everything it's not
due north it's Northwest due north
everything I know about geography which
is extremely limited I only know because
of tour like I know nothing about
geography from school that was like not
even a class I took
um it depends on the on the location you
know I like to pride myself on being an
Arbiter of New York geography because I
went to school Upstate but I don't know
where the [__] no but there are parts of
New York and parts of Pennsylvania that
are so far away it's crazy yeah
that I knew yeah like Syracuse
Utica yeah I know that's Upstate like
classic classic where all the colleges
are yeah but also classic is like Hudson
Valley Upstate yeah that's like [__]
State because yeah yeah
um what was the story oh yeah Josh Allen
and Haley Seinfeld here for it Josh
Allen like I know nothing about football
I don't even I think I think he plays
for Buffalo like I really know nothing
beyond that he said pride and joy at
Buffalo and they're really passionate
fans but he I what I know about him is
he had old tweets and he went from like
the number one draft pick to like number
90 and had like all this promise and I
relate to him because like you know
things from our past should not come
back to haunt you and I really felt bad
for him in that moment
um and he got it together now he's like
a great contract but like he was like
number one kid you know from that year
and he had like some song lyrics you
know with inappropriate words and his
life was over and I honestly I feel like
you've told that story before but I
genuinely forgotten that's so great it's
all I think about but because he's
obviously accomplished a lot since then
I feel like every time I walk past the
TV when Zach's watching sports it's a
package about Josh Allen how he gives
back to his community does he yeah like
he's really the beacon they love him he
loves him but you know you know who else
Buffalo loved who was a beacon of their
community
OJ
so maybe they don't have a great
barometer radar yeah
okay well way to ruin a beautiful story
those are just like there are a few
things I know about football and one of
them is that like OJ was like the king
of Buffalo
was is that really his like he played
for a few teams but yeah Buffalo was
like it was like like that's where his
greatest moment that's like LeBron and
the Cavaliers exactly or no like LeBron
in the heat no the heat was just like a
transient experience so he could get he
was taking his talents to South Beach
yeah so he could get a a ring but he's
Cleveland like he's yeah you're right
you're right you're right he's Cavaliers
King Charles
um should we dive into this section
recap before our interview we shall so
last night's well two nights ago this
episode the series finale of succession
let me tell you how I will not miss the
show but like of course and I've been
very hard on it this the entire year of
course the final episode like was good
as it should well no it it ended really
good like now I could say the episode
was good but there were times while I
was watching it where I was like how
much longer is this episode oh I didn't
feel that way I thought it was a very
good episode of TV I need to get to the
board meeting but the the fact that like
the board meeting didn't go that the
kids like didn't stick together right it
was like this climax like you know the
kids are fighting but then they go to
the Caribbean and they work on it
together and they all finally agree like
it really can only be Kendall and then
they're having fun in the kitchen and
they're walking in there together and
they're strong and they're a team Peak
and then like Roman starts to break a
little bit and shiv obviously breaks
during the meeting and it really was
like a roller coaster and I enjoyed it
even better like having to suffer
through them pretending to be like good
siblings to each other and like having
like a fun kitchen moment yeah and like
just like thinking that they're like a
cute family right just like not they're
not
um it was like kind of painful to watch
but I know that like for the fans of
like the kids they probably ate that up
yeah uh but then to see it all come
crashing down was like really justifying
for me but it was interesting because
for so long like I was on I was on
Logan's side when he was alive like his
kids were really entitled and they
didn't deserve his business and they
just wanted it because they thought they
should have it not because they actually
earned deserved or are good for it right
and this was his thing that he built as
like worse than being just like lazy and
entitled they actively worked against
him in the last year of his life as
stressful as possible so I was on team
Logan and then when Logan was out of the
picture I didn't really know where to
land and I think for a while like the
most tolerable kid was Roman yes and
over the last season like I just found
myself not being able to root for him
and he definitely got you know a little
ahead of himself and with the Jerry
thing like he was just [__] weird and
like kind of gross and all like the
gross stuff he used to say like at first
it was like a part of his personality
but in this last year I was like ew like
yeah he couldn't refer him no and he was
definitely my favorite kid I missed the
last two episodes or I just saw pieces
of them so I don't really he seems to
have some sort of breakdown
um but I also will remember to like the
first season when he was like really I
don't know what the word is but like
Twisted yeah you know dark dark and like
even the first episode there was like
something with the watch and one of the
kids like he was just like gross and and
I can't think of what the word was but
then when so I think of him as CEO I'm
like you're not the right person either
like you're into like dark stuff and
they all they have too much baggage
Kendall and um Roman Roman obviously
Kendall's murderer and Roman but also
like aside from the murder which is not
not a good thing not good to murder
um he literally like brought all that
Cruise's stuff to light like he tried so
many different ways to destroy the
company destroy the company like why
would you be at them so now he cares
about keeping it in the family right
like you tried to take it from your dad
so many times to give it to no one like
when he was working on his like other
projects like the Art Collective thing
like I just I can't and then shiv like
she's the only one who doesn't have like
this you know skeleton filled closet but
she's the least qualified she's never
worked at the company she like took on a
passion project and like worked in
politics for a while but she knows
nothing about running a business and
she's probably the most entitled out of
any of them because she's the least
qualified and really was the last one
who would give it up to Kendall like she
was the one who took the most convincing
but what was interesting is like by the
end I kind of did find myself being like
well it should be Kendall and like when
he didn't get it I was like oh like it
was a weird mix of I hate these kids
none of them are deserving but by the
end I'm like well it should be Kendall
like I did want them to keep the
business in the family because it was
what Logan wanted but they did keep the
business in the family well by proxy
through shiv through Tom right now
but also Logan was selling to Gojo right
and he wanted to and that's true to stop
the deal that's true actually and he was
literally going over there to make the
deal happen so you could say Logan
wanted this logo and wanted that I don't
I really don't think that Beyond his
lifetime Logan cared what happened or
else he would have had like a much more
stable plan concrete will and everything
now the Arc of Siobhan
you know girl bossing her way to the top
without ever like working a real job
only to end up as the wife of the CEO
when she started out as the daughter of
the CEO like is too rich honestly like
the the final scene of the car like
where she's literally just taking his
hand waiting for him in the car it was
really ironic and it was very well done
like it was poetic how she just tried to
girl boss her way to the top
and you know she was always the like
token woman in the room but she really
had no reason like she had no
business being there like Beyond being a
woman like she that was actually like
her only qualification to like to shake
things up right her like even at times
throughout the seasons when like Logan
would kind of turn to her like she might
have been the future of the companies
because she's like a woman right and
she's
could be more ushering in a new era
um but no now she's just resigned to
being a baby maker right no and so like
for that scene I thought like the most
powerful scene was when they got in the
car and like Tom this like Dopey [__]
[__] who actually was the only one who
like got up and went to work every day
you know what he actually gets the job
like it was so honestly brilliant
it was brilliant I can't believe that it
turned out so beautifully like I just
assumed it would be a an ending that I
would hate because I've hated most of
the show but like
Tom is I mean Everyone likes Tom and
Greg the best I do think they're that
they're the least insufferable but also
when it comes to like who's doing work
who knows how the business Works who is
typing and sitting at a desk right who's
looking at papers and things not just
being like call gotta fly yeah right
right like actually doing a job
it's time he's worked in cruises he
didn't yeah and he worked for the
company for as long as like he's known
ship like he has qualifications yeah
maybe he's not the smartest guy in the
rumor you know he's not going to be but
they don't need the smartest guy in the
room they have Matson the the the person
is a puppet and it shiv Kendall and
Roman we're never going to be what
Matson means and when Madison said like
I don't want more ideas right that's so
Tom I felt that you know and that's
literally Tom to a t like he was up
Logan's ass he was up shib's ass like he
would just do what people told him to do
like when Tom has asked a question he
will give both answers yes and no yep
he's like well I could do this but also
I could see that and I see value in both
yeah what did you think about like him
forgiving Greg in that final moment
like they had been through it all in the
very end like Greg [__] it so bad yeah
Greg I think that he should forgive Greg
because like he's gonna need people by
his time and who understands better than
Tom like needing to throw someone under
the bus for your own person and also
like needing to play but like Tom was
playing both sides the whole time too
like trying to stay in everyone's good
graces so I think he'll forgive Greg
because it worked out if it hadn't
worked out like no so what do you think
happens to the Roman uh the Roy kids now
well they have a ton of money yeah
because they sold because they sold so
they are buying Pierce still question
mark whatever happened to that what
happened to the 10 billion whole episode
that we had to watch right but no I mean
like are they forgiving each other like
is it irreparable I heard Shivan and
Kendall gonna be like you know Logan and
his brother
I don't think it's referable because all
throughout the seasons they like hated
each other on off on offense they'll
never like be actual good siblings to
each other family because they're
incapable but I just think it's another
part of the up and down yeah maybe
they'll start the hundred and the way
that like Roman went so hard only to
just give up like he didn't even care
like he had like when he was co-ceo with
Kendall he had like a two-week period
where he was a [__] nut job like
calling the election just because he
felt like it like really nuts and then
right after that he stopped caring like
he went to the Caribbean and even at the
board like he didn't care anymore no
even they're trying to have a
conversation about which way they're
going to vote and he's walking away and
it's like well you're not kid you can't
even have a conversation how you think
you should be CEO right now of all of
them on it's a tie for Kendall for It's
A Time shiv enrollment it's a tie three
for who's the best choice and it's a tie
of three for who's the voice no if there
is a choice it's Kendall no because that
doesn't mean he's a good choice Kendall
did the most harm to the company over
the years yeah and Roman's mom worked
for the company he worked in LA in the
studio yeah but like
well that's that on that goodbye goodbye
but like I just want to say I loved how
it shook up me too me too it was really
kind of stunning and honestly I think
Logan would have liked it too I think so
number two and also Tom was the only one
who never betrayed Logan
because he's a puppet yeah
he's a pawn so really Matson is in
charge yeah and the company moves into
the future with the eccentric Tech CEO
yeah
yeah and I guess like Tom is going to
wipe out everyone who was like they
never included him like Frank Carl Jerry
he's wiping them all out he's the big
man now and he's got like vendettas yeah
now he's like as an actual powerful
person
he's more powerful than all the people
who he like sought attention from yeah
who never gave it to him but I could
also see him keeping them on and like
just making them grovel oh yes because
he's also like a little bit like
Machiavellian evil yeah he likes to do
with Greg yeah he's got more power yeah
yeah yeah and he's going to be a father
everything's coming up Tom I'm ready for
the Tom sequel the Tom spin-off yeah
that's interesting yeah and I don't know
maybe it was because he was like finally
in charge but I was like yeah Tom's Hot
yeah also obviously Tom and shiv are not
a love match and when they were finally
like honest with each other on the
balcony like that was really refreshing
but I also feel like they can make it
work you know I ship yeah like I don't
think that I mean I hope to God for her
like that's really all she has
yeah well no she has like billions of
dollars now she have a baby right you
can get into charity work and she could
also like meet someone else but I think
like this life is the life that she's
meant for you know your husband's a CEO
of Ray star royco yeah it's nice okay
couldn't be me but but I really
appreciated her about face and then by
the end I got it you know it's like
should be Kendall who is the devil you
know the devil you know Tom or the devil
you don't the devil you like she
controls like can control Tom Kendall is
like so wild and really like a wild card
Loose Cannon she chose Tom over Kendall
and if that ain't saying a lot then I
don't know what is yeah you would do it
too you would do it too
so that's your succession series finale
recap but don't be upset the episode is
not over please continue listening for
our interview with Brooke EB she is a
delight I think you guys will love her
it's a great fun-filled episode an
interview and that's our show so without
further Ado I present to you bro the
interview the inimitable Brooke EB the
wickedly talented Brooke EB goodbye
goodbye
welcome back to the toast we are so
excited to be sitting down with an
extremely special guest we have a
toaster we have an advocate we have a
tick tocker jealous
um we are sitting down with Brooke EB
who is a toaster by in her heart correct
and my heart deep in there okay God
um but she's also a tick tocker who has
been documenting her amazing journey
with her terminal diagnosis of ALS her
tick tocks were popping up all over my
for you page like a week ago and then
everyone started tagging me in one of
her videos she had been asked you know
is there any sort of list you have sort
of like an ALS Bucket List that you
would love to do and one of the things
on her list was to come on the toast so
I was not okay immediately you know had
to make everything about myself and I
reached out and a few days later here
you are hello Brooke welcome to the
toast oh my gosh thank you so much I
know I was listening to your show a
couple days ago and I was like guys I
manifested this it's like no everyone
tagged Claudia yeah see that's the same
thing that's what manifestation is
that's what you call it these days so
thank you so much for having me we're so
excited to have you and we're so
flattered that we were wonderful part of
your life and that this is such an honor
I know it was like an eight bullet list
I call it the adult Make-a-Wish and
toasters on there that is such an honor
for us we are so excited to have you so
I'm sure you know a lot of people have
seen your tick tocks it's ALS awareness
month so a lot of your posts have been
going really viral but for some of our
you know not Tick Tock friendly users
and listeners even though you are
unreals she is my real fans yeah real
fans are real fans a hundred percent I
said it she said it she said it um tell
us about your journey a you know your
diagnosis how long it's been going on
and then your decision to document the
whole journey on tick tock yeah
absolutely so I started having symptoms
in 2018. I I actually was listening to
the toast throughout my four-year
diagnosis period so this is a bizarre
coming of coming-of-age moment but I
started limping in 2018 like I work in
the corporate world I was living in New
York City
and I just started limping on the way to
a conference and all my co-workers were
like you should probably get that
checked out and I did but they could not
find anything for basically a year then
I had basically four years of testing
um where they could not diagnose me they
couldn't figure anything out and then
beginning of last year I started
noticing I was limping on the other side
as well which is when they were able to
test me and officially give me an ALS
diagnosis which some people know it's
Lou Gehrig's disease
um all the baseball people know it is
disease I know I don't look much like
him so I don't know who's selling and
smart
um but yeah so four years of diagnosis
are really the diagnosis process and
then once I was diagnosed it took me
like two to three months of straight
depression like sitting in my bed binge
eating M M's I listened to your book on
tape like all of these things all of
these things come back to the totes but
um yeah I I didn't know what to do and I
was just like how do I process this how
do I grieve what I thought you know my
30s were going to be the rest of my life
was going to be
and then I had to go to a wedding where
you've probably seen this on Tick Tock
but I had to use a walker at a wedding
with all of my college friends like can
you imagine anything more embarrassing
than like waddling your way in and your
bridesmaid dress
um but like an hour into it the bride
was limboing under my Walker I was
giving people walking rides all over the
dance floor like it just ended up being
so fun yeah and so I was like you know
what I feel like I should start sharing
this story with more people because if
I'm able to laugh about it and I think
people are so scared to ask questions
about anything serious when it comes to
like a terminal diagnosis no one wants
to say the wrong thing they're afraid of
being like inappropriate or you know
offensive but I figured if I could laugh
about it and start making videos about
it then maybe we could spread the word a
little bit more yeah I mean because when
I saw your tick tocks I'm like oh my God
this girl has such energy like she
radiates positivity and you're always
smiling but I was curious if like you
know when you first got the diagnosis
there was like a dark period because I
think that's a very natural reaction
it was Bleak yeah it was a couple months
of just like survival
um and I was not in a good place when
people would ask me about it like I
couldn't talk about it so I actually
think making videos for like Tick Tock
and real of course um have both have
really made me comfortable talking about
it and I just feel like we can laugh
about it a little bit now even though
some people write like why is she
smiling and I'm like I can't help it
you have a beautiful smile oh thank you
so much yeah I feel like you know
there's so many I think people don't
want to tap dance and don't want to say
the wrong thing but I think your
attitude is so amazing like even I and
that's very much my our philosophy Like
You Gotta Laugh about things in life
because you know you'll drive yourself
crazy if you don't and I'm curious what
the reception to your videos like you
you go deep you talk and I I learned so
much from your tick tocks like you know
you said you were working in the
corporate world and then you did a whole
video on like your job situation so I
feel like it's really educational and
there is a Natural Curiosity
yeah I think I mean I've largely been
Amazed by the reception like I know that
the social media worlds can get to a
really dark and mean place so the first
couple videos I was so nervous to post
like I made my best friend being the
first one because I'm like you're going
down with me we get if we get
embarrassed
um but ever since I get like
pretty much all nice responses and a lot
of them are a lot of them are questions
too like people want to know like how do
you feel about you know like assisted
death it's like very dark questions but
I want people to feel comfortable asking
them so it's been really nice and I
would say like 99 are about ALS and then
like one percent is about my hair always
or my hair or you look like blank I I
don't know if you could get these two
but like you look like blanks are so
effective they're psycho okay Claudia
hate that what who do you get yeah who
do you get okay I'll tell you the nice
ones first and then I'll end on the
Whopper because it has been haunting me
I get
um
who's that singer uh Phoebe Bridges I
get her okay and then I get Ellen Pompeo
a lot yes
um I get a couple Lindsay Lohan's but I
think that's just because my hair is
reddish yeah but the cruelest one and I
can I have the screenshots still cause
I'm like I can never forget this it said
you look like pregnant Blake Lively
because her lips were thinner
people are not [__] okay bro like not
only is it like so you look like like
Lively at her worst plus mine is a
really good quality first right so yeah
that was a dark one and I wrote back
like why did you have to stay pregnant
and she never responded right I think
you actually look like Megan Faye from
yes yeah I've gotten that one like twice
and I've like I wish Tick Tock didn't
take away the pinning thing because I
would have pinched out like uh I'll take
that all day you do that's a really good
call see it's only okay to tell someone
who you think their celebrity
doppelganger is if they're celebrity
doppelganger is like insanely beautiful
no but like I feel like someone could
think they're paying you a compliment
and then you think actually that person
is like less beautiful than you so it
could go either way which is why it's
like never really a great thing to do
when my Claudia takes so much umbrage
with it yeah but I do think it's a fun
exercise usually a little game yeah I've
never heard it before with a preemptive
pregnant though like that has to be a
very new game you know when she's not
pregnant it you look nothing like her
yeah no I don't see it
kind of really changed obviously because
of your diagnosis but also because of
your Tick Tock like I know you were on
the Today Show recently yeah tell me
about that oh my gosh it was crazy like
the social media world is so crazy to me
because I I mean you guys have been
doing it for so long like I just started
a tick tock last summer and I basically
had to YouTube like how to make a tick
tock like none of it was new to me or
none of it was you know
common to me and so I just started
making videos hoping for the best some
of them would get like no views and then
if I posted a dating one like it would
go viral and so I was like okay there's
something here like if I can capture
people's attention for like 10 seconds
then maybe they'll start being more
interested in learning about ALS because
I don't think many people know what ALS
is like ice bucket challenge is probably
about it yeah
um and so I just sort of started going
for it and like you think back to when
you have like you know 40 followers and
the videos I was posting I'm like how
was I not a little embarrassed like
talking into my camera like hey guys
so yeah the Today Show reached out to me
on
on Instagram they dm'd me like hey we
want to write an article about you and
about your diagnosis
um and once that article came out the
producer of the actual show was like hey
we want to have you on our show
um and so I went like two weeks ago I
was in the city it was the most blur of
a morning I've ever had but it was so
cool like that's Savannah she's
something else
something else she is something else so
who do you have around you during this
time like what what is your village like
yeah so I I work all day what do you do
I work at Salesforce so I'm in Tech and
I'm technically on the clock right now
so I'm just pardon my job you guys are
my clients yeah 100 and we need help
with our sales force so we're hoping
that you can give us those tools exactly
I'll give you all the tips
um so during the day literally yeah no I
keep saying their name and I'm like
should I just say a big tech company
because I don't know it sounds like I'm
being paid by them
um so it's just me and my dog during the
day mostly
um and then my family lives like all
within the Maryland area so my parents
are 10 minutes away for half the year
they're actually in Florida the other
half in Jupiter and then my sister's
like 40 minutes away my boyfriend's like
30 minutes away so I've and I have a
bunch of neighbors who have like quickly
become my friends because I'll be like
guys I can't load my wheelchair into my
car and they'll have to come like be my
muscle
um so yeah I I feel like in the weirdest
way I would set up for the easiest
version of having a really bad diagnosis
I had a really good group of friends at
a really close family I'm still getting
a paycheck like everything was kind of
set for me to be able to say okay let's
just focus on the problem at hand yeah
and how long have you been with your
boyfriend
um
seven months oh so I started I started
dating in post-diagnosis
um yeah he's a little nuts for doing
that but I I met him so he's my sister's
husband's best friend so I've known him
I know I know I know people are like you
need to write a a rom-com about that yes
you do Claudia would read it as long as
it's smart extra spicy yeah yeah no
probably not
um but yeah so we we met like 15 years
ago at my sister's wedding I think it
was probably the first time
but we never lived in the same place I
was always in New York or San Francisco
he was always in Maryland and so when I
moved back my sister was like well I
think it's time and so we just like
started texting and then we hung out but
then I was diagnosed so I went dark on
him for like months
and then once I started coming too he
like invited me to a wedding which I
quickly said no to because I was like I
will not show up in with a cane in your
wedding
um but yeah we started dating shortly
after that and uh it's been good it's
weird dating with like this sort of
hanging over you you have to ask some
really serious questions early on like
the kids question had to come up on like
date two yeah
um I think on day three I was like so if
my arms ever stop working like would you
wipe my butt like you have to ask him
really uncomfortable wonderful questions
and it's like these are all things that
were probably at some point have to ask
our partners right but like not when you
are like in your 30s you know right not
you know a few months recording and like
showing you know right like showing your
own even like fart yeah right right I
will start but can you wipe my ass
that's exactly the phase we are in at
seven months so that's the perfect
explanation were you like actively
seeking out a relationship was dating a
priority for you when you met him
do I just write it in my profile like
hey I'm terminal but also cute like get
at me and so I mean so you you are
awesome
I made I made a profile and I just like
I was getting like a lot of nice
responses I just really didn't know how
to handle it so I kind of just avoided
like I didn't want to have to tell a
stranger on the first date about this
stuff like especially on dating apps
when you know you're like a swipe away
from another option I just was like not
confident enough for it
and so I kind of had given up on the
idea of a relationship period I was like
I guess you know that's just not really
going to be part of my life I have other
things to focus on now I have this
purpose and then Brian just came
crawling in you know obsessed I know
he's a cutie so all in all like when you
look back on the last few years and the
journey you have ahead of you like how
how do you describe it like what is your
disposition like I know you feel very
compelled to like Advocate and have more
people know about ALS but like on a
personal level like does the future
scare you at all
so this is sort of a weird thing to try
to explain because I I don't think I
could
understand it unless I was given this
diagnosis but for me like I do not
picture a future
and that sounds so sad but it's honestly
I think it's my brain protecting me like
I honestly think we all have really
protective brains because once I was
diagnosed those two to three months I
was thinking like okay so I'm not gonna
have kids I'm probably not gonna you
know like be this corporate Baddie that
I thought I was gonna be like all of
that just kind of I was grieving it but
once I kind of got past that I was like
uh now if anyone asks me like oh what
are your plans you know for when you
progress further I'm like
couldn't tell you like I don't my brain
just doesn't want to go there
um and so I don't really think about the
future and I actually think it's made me
a lot happier like it's it's almost a
relief in a sense because you're like I
don't have to worry about everything I
was worrying about before yeah it's
really just about like making sure I'm
happy making sure I feel good and it's
like
Claudia if you don't break out and to
live like we were dying at one point yes
I did I feel it Like You Were Dying no
by the way I feel like that's actually a
really healthy way of looking at things
like that's definitely a defense
mechanism for like your psyche right to
protect you but I think that actually
sounds really healthy and and gives you
the ability to wake up every day
positive and be happy yeah and and just
take and I think that's what everyone
does on some level like you're just
trying to make it through one day at a
time right like we all never know how
how things are going to work out for us
but if we can make it through today
we'll be okay
exactly
well we know you're a big pop culture
girly and you wanted to count on the
toes so we're gonna toast we're gonna do
the toast treatment
I would like really wanted to learn as
fast as you did the ending but I
couldn't do it it's like truly a skill
no the thing is but you could you could
practice and like you could do your own
ending like when Claudia doesn't do it
and I do it like I kind of ad-libs so
when we close it's all you it's okay
but do your own thing with it yeah okay
okay maybe we'll get something that
become a new ending something fresh we
love fresh
so a lot going on in the universe right
now Kardashians like kind of going
through this unique period
what is what is your take on the current
state give us like a state of the union
on the Kardashians right now they could
give us so much exposure in the ALS
world they're so famous
yeah
and I think my next Tic Tac series is
going to be like pitching celebrities on
why they should donate to ALS and I feel
like Kylie would be a really easy one to
do because like I already have the lip
kits I could just like talk like her
talk you know self her a little bit so I
think that's going to be my next series
is that you know like an issue in the
ALS Community like searching for a cure
is it a lack of funds
it it's very underfunded and it's crazy
because like the ice bucket challenge
raised 150 million dollars wow that
helped fund like one medication and so
it's it's not a matter of like them you
know not knowing
there's there's a lot that needs to be
done like we don't understand why people
get it we don't understand why people
progress faster with it than others and
so I think research money towards
research is really what my focus has
been in terms of funding that's where I
donate a lot of my money
um and so yeah I I feel like the concept
of it being underfunded like needs to be
more friend Center yeah yeah I didn't
realize that I didn't realize that
either what other kinds of funding is
there for ALS aside from like uh
research like is there for medication
there's like buckets yeah there's like I
would say there's like the Cure bucket
and that's like research and medications
and then there's like the care side of
things where patients you know need like
wheelchairs they need adaptations they
need
um like feeding tube surgery like
basically with ALS all of your muscles
stop working so like one by one you
become fully paralyzed and that includes
like your lungs can stop like your
swallowing can stop your speech is gone
so like everything is basically like
machine
relying on machines at a certain point
and so the care bucket is really like
making sure that patients have what they
need yeah um because I think like a lot
of people I mean with any disability
like you're more likely to go into
serious poverty
so that's the other bucket and like like
I said I I feel really lucky that I'm
still working so I have the money to
take care of that part for myself so I
focus on giving more money to research
but people have their preferences yeah
no it gets expensive
yeah our you know whole life in the last
few months has revolved around Tom
Sandoval and his insane mustache and
just horrible personality what is your
take like obviously your team Ariana but
you have any you have any thoughts on
the situation that takes you want to
share with the class yeah perhaps I just
can't get over he keeps popping up on my
Tick Tock like he's banned yeah keeps
popping behind me Tick Tock the accent
work he was doing like he thinks that's
a skill like he was home practicing
Accents in the mirror before these shows
no he really threw it up like Elton John
like that's the type of delusional
person we're working with here yes like
he thinks he's gonna be like a one Namer
in the future yeah sure Tom exactly it's
brutal like every time I'm like so ready
to swipe away and then I'm like is he
singing you know that 99 Red Balloons
yeah yeah like full Scottish accent as
he's doing it it's so it's so painful to
watch he's so weird I can't imagine like
being in the front row as his girlfriend
being like that's Mom no that's such a
good point like imagine I could that
honestly could never be me
or you just feel like blindly supportive
but man brutal what about succession are
you watching succession
it's like the worst show thank you thank
you of all time I have watched
everything yes yeah no you can I'm
terminal people can't come for me
they that show is like
it has had the same plot of every
episode for like every single season
yeah and you think of the finale like
they'd be going out with a bang honestly
like the episode where Logan died was
like
a nice change but then they went right
they went right back to it in The
Following episode and it's like
Ken uh Kendall yeah Kendall's like back
to being a little nutty yeah yeah the
whole thing is just so painful to watch
I can't I can't believe and you don't
like Tom and Greg that's the only like
thing that can kind of get me through it
that's what a lot of people say but I
see right through them
I I like Tom Greg doesn't so much do it
for me I also feel like Greg
like there were a bunch of lines about
him like yes being super creepy in clubs
and that kind of like ruined the Greg
character by the way I completely I
thought he was like so beloved he was
and then like you know his ability is a
prison and there was um all these blinds
none of it is confirmed but like he's
like being accused of being like really
[__] weird just like taking home a
lot of girls and like talking about how
he's on the show who knows if it's true
like I mean he's like a tall cute guy I
don't I feel like he doesn't need it but
yeah yeah it just kind of ruins his
character for me but Tom still has me I
definitely when it's enjoyable at times
but also he gets on the hamster wheel of
like not stopping talking about nothing
yeah he's tolerable sometimes so what
other things were on your list I
actually I got shiv I got shiv too
it is hard to see on yourself yes like
so many people will tell me I look like
someone I'm like I really don't see it
but I guess if everybody says it they're
so yeah there's something shiv is a
really weird character too like I feel
like every time they focus on her she's
making crazy eyes and they're playing
scary music and I'm like is this
supposed to be deeper than I'm thinking
it is I don't understand I'm just I'm
not into the show I'm really glad it's
ending me too
um okay we can you walk me through some
of the other things on your list like
when when you had to sit down and be
like these are the things I would love
to do what is like what name a few of
them and then what's like the thing that
you your number one number one
I think they're pretty equally weighted
honestly but one of them was have
um a lunch with like Amy Poehler Tina
Fey like that group of girls because I
feel like if you have a lunch with them
like they'll get to know you and they'll
like you and then you'll be friends
forever
yeah it's like the multiple wishes
situation so that's right and then it's
just the start of your friendship know
but like I also was like they can bring
whoever they want to like if they want
to bring like Steve Carell or Kristen
wig like I am down yeah
um so that was one the other is like
having a sleepover with Taylor Swift so
she can tell me secrets I honestly think
like I could be a really good vessel for
celebrity Secrets because like for all
they know I could die tomorrow and so
it's like it I want to know like what
happened in that Beyonce elevator like I
should be the one to know no and you
deserve to know
I deserve it I've earned this yeah I've
a really big Swifty
um I am I am although I'm not going to
the concert because
well one I like didn't want to go
through the hellscape of ticketing but
two like in a wheelchair I don't really
know how that works I imagine they have
like sections they do I have actually
heard the concert I feel I feel bad like
the people in front of me would feel bad
standing I know by the way to feel no
you're totally fine I've actually heard
Taylor's concert is very Ada friendly
and most stadiums are like there are
sections and you're at the front of the
section like you're you're you're
perched you actually have some of the
best seats in the joint okay so I should
have added that to my Make-a-Wish I mean
although people are like when I did that
Make-a-Wish I thought it was going to be
a fun activity where everyone would
write their make a wishes yeah and
instead like people started tagging like
Taylor Nation Taylor Nation Claudia
ashrae I was like oh God this is like
taking a turn for like actual
Make-a-Wish like I was thinking it would
be I was thinking it would be like a
little fun activity where I get to see
like what people want to do have other
people reach out like our other wishes
gonna come true
um
so the one of them was hang out with the
penguin which like some of these I just
put in like as to be like funny like one
of them I wrote to have the Friends cast
call me their friend and people tagged
Courtney Cox I'm like no you know what
Courtney Cox is always thirsting out on
Tick Tock I'm telling you she's gonna
respond to you perhaps
um yeah the penguin one a lot of people
have been contacting zoos on my behalf
and I'm like I probably could have done
this one myself and I just like did
money put in the effort but well I just
think you're fabulous I think you're
just a gorgeous girly with such a great
energy and such a beautiful smile and I
have loved chatting with you and the
fact that the toast in any tiny way has
been a part of your journey makes me so
happy and I just can't thank you enough
for coming and chatting with us thank
you so much I've loved being here a
pleasure we loved having you you guys
make sure to follow tick a girl your
[__] Tick Tock username what the [__]
is that oh my God we have to talk about
it so yeah if I want to plug it and I
can't even say it yeah
um I didn't like I said when I started
Tick Tock I had like 10 followers and I
was talking to myself most of the time
so I started my symptoms started with a
limp and so you know the band lymphis
kit of course I get my reference I threw
my name in the middle of it so it's limp
bruise kit but come to find out that
Limp Biscuit is like a very filthy sex
act did you know this oh be right back
hold on let me just only get on Urban
Dictionary only like the men only was
only a certain percentage of men in my
life have come forward to be like you
might want to think about changing it
because if I if I'm using you know it's
not a common one right and I mean Limp
Biscuit sounds like it's so much more
common oh my god do you want to read it
out loud yes
use your judgment according to Urban
Dictionary oh wait oh my God I'm
literally getting a virus okay several
guys stand in a circle around a biscuit
they all begin to jerk off ejaculating
onto the biscuit I'm not reading the
last sentence Oh there's wait there's
more oh the last person to finish
ejaculating has to eat the biscuit like
I based my I
basically disability awareness campaign
off of that listen it is not too late to
change your username I know well now
Tick Tock just shows like Brooke Evie
yeah I feel like it's fine it's kind of
hidden
um yeah but yeah I I really committed I
tied uh What's the phrase like I tied my
horse to the wrong post or whatever
yeah yeah something like that I get what
you're saying well yeah it was tough if
you're looking for Brook's Tick Tock
just search Brook EB
b-r-o-o-k-e space e b y right yeah
that's perfect such a pleasure thank you
so much for joining us toaster's follow
Brooke send her love tell her beautiful
celebrities she looks like and keep
doing the fabulous work that you're
doing it was such an honor to get to
talk to you seriously thank you for
coming on oh my gosh thank you so much
for having me this is so surreal this is
okay okay
okay thank you so much for listening to
the test this do you still do Millennial
Morning Show the millennial Morning Show
uh we go live feel free to subscribe we
go live and then it's like stitchers
Dreamcast podcast you nailed it yeah
that that is my my pop culture moment in
history is wickedly talented I say it
all the time I said it in one of my Tic
Tacs and people started commenting like
I knew you were a toaster and I was like
oh my God there's something about like
the w
like the wind up
it's like he added an H after the W it's
like yes it's like a whistle is there
something so strange about that whole
thing like that's another secret I want
to get in yeah by the way because there
was something going on that day yeah I
mean there's something going on with
John Travolta period all the time I need
to know it all add it to the list add it
to the list of secrets that is so funny
well you guys make sure to follow Brooke
thank you so much for joining us and you
guys will see you on tomorrow's episode
bye love you bye